this man has been in a lot of great
television shows and films and even
better for him and us as fans he is
great in everything that he does
Parenthood Kingdom justified city on a
hill the Virgin Suicides just to name a
few and now in theaters near you part of
a great cast in a movie written and
directed by the hilarious and awesome
Elizabeth Banks it is called Charlie's
Angels it's starring in part Jonathan
Tucker's you sir
yeah how are you I'm great I mean you
know and we should add the Elizabeth
Banks Massachusetts girl yes born and
raised so you sure it's fan yes you
shared your love yeah of the same New
England's horse watching those games on
our DirecTV app you know overseas having
to figure out how to you know get the
get the right Wi-Fi so that it would
allow us to not be blacked out so you
get cuz you shot a lot of this stuff in
Germany Germany right Germany and Turkey
in terms of Germany and Turkey so you're
they're checking on last year's
asteroids of the patroness correct okay
and which which you know which I guess
screen were you able to watch it I'm
like on a phone on my little phone and
it's just great being in like the oldest
a film studio in the entire world in in
outside just outside of Berlin studio
babbles berg right and these historical
German studios watching the greatest
football franchise in NFL history with
with another fan you know and that's an
exciting thing to do when you're talking
about greatest football franchise in NFL
history I'm talking about you are you
pointing a Brockman over there don't you
bunny don't I see some action don't card
he's gonna play till he's 47 years old
it's unbelievable 47 white women 57 it's
incredibly and we all know in the next
it has to happen the Saturday after buy
the Saturday after Thanksgiving the
phone call from the 508 or 6 1 7 area
code to the 3:05 area code telling Gronk
we need you faxing he did he looked a
very skinny and that I saw he looks he's
having a good time he'd obviously but it
doesn't mean doesn't look like he's let
himself go though no no surely I mean it
just seemed like if Kraft
or Brady because I don't think it'll be
Belichick it'll be somebody on his proxy
sends up the bat signal from what would
the signal be would it be flash of CBD
cartridge in the sky and get drunk back
hopefully he can pee in a cup and we're
all good although that CBD stuff it's
you know it's suppose we're supposed to
be good but sure yeah and all of a
sudden Airy is taking on like s what
like the Houston Texans all of a sudden
that would be a lot of fun I'd say the
bank's I mean she's the real deal man I
mean she's not just really really
talented as a real director or an
actress but she's like she's you know
she is a fun person to be around man she
is down-to-earth as they come right and
yeah and now she's crushing it with this
new movie it's so cool I mean I grew up
on Charlie's Angels yeah I mean I'm I
will admit I'm going to just come out
here and admit it cuz I share things on
this show sometimes I over share but on
my bicycle that I had as a kid I had a
Jaclyn Smith sticker on my pot I think
that's a great thing to share I did that
was she was she was my angel well this
is a hold there's a whole new kind of
whole new deal I mean it's a real update
from from the previous movies in the TV
show and it's uh it kind of gives
another generation their their their
Charlie's Angels right I am NOT saying
this to like push a movie I'm telling
you straight up it is a lot of fun I
mean you will have a good time at this
movie and you're kicking some ass until
you know it so it's a movie where these
women are pushing a message of self
empowerment and my characters job is to
stymie that was to stop that put an end
to that I do not win I do not win that's
the case that's right yeah I mean I've
cause like I just think it's awesome and
obviously Elizabeth Banks is hilarious
and the factory Stewart's and he plays
this over-the-top bag guys he says
caracal I got to go on a walking tour of
Istanbul Turkey with Patrick Stewart
what is that
so you know it's everything you can
possibly imagine and more it is just an
absolute privilege to be strolling
through the historic city of Istanbul
Turkey with Sir Patrick Stewart is
amazingly talented singer wife Sonny I
mean it was it was just great that's
fine now were you on the set at the same
time as Strahan no he I think he can be
there was all these really great cameos
in the Patrick but the problem is the
Patriots were too busy winning winning a
Super Bowl for them to be in this film
actually true you know that I'm sure
they up they probably what they wanted
Edelman they wanted sounds like he would
be a perfect guy for a Charlie's Angels
movie he would actually be a great
villain and or you know what great
character in the in the in the next
French write in the sequel Jonathan
Tucker here on the Rich Eisen showing
again you're one of my favorite guests
despite the fact that I do believe the
first or maybe second time you appeared
on this show you took a Yankee hat and
my shirt was it a shirt yes resting in
the dressing room and mocked flushing it
down the green the toilet yeah well or
did you mock it that so as you say cut
right before you cut right yeah it's a
terrible team we've talked about it
every time I come on here and utj your
friend here on the show asked me
backstage he said would you rather the
Patriots get to the Super Bowl and win I
was like of course that's the answer or
nope the first one or the Patriots get
to the Super Bowl and lose but the
Yankees don't win a World Series
championship for the next decade oh boy
you really knew how to get me of course
the latter because nothing is better
than being from Boston and nothing is
better than subscribing to a famous
Boston cheer which is Yankee sunk so
even when you win another sport another
game in another sport the fans are still
standing up cheering Bob Lobel and
Yankees suck well you know what Jonathan
I find that particularly galling yeah
and sad we're a classy town I find it
sad but I also find it typical sure be
classic no no here's what's typical huh
is that a sports fan norm
just deep down just the basic concept of
being a sports fan surrounds love love
for team love yeah city just I love this
you need a lump on Sue's me sorry right
now it's our show even though you do we
do sometimes need to remind people what
the show is called here on the Richard
she's not even paying attention over
there don't worry Mike it's okay the
drop about what the name of this show
Mike you have that this is the Rich
Eisen show oh my gosh nailed it
but love love of team love of city love
of Schleyer loving that guy loving that
gal love it love and yet for Boston
sports yeah in particular we even here
our own team you're not you're not happy
unless you're unhappy
yeah about something but I will say and
we talk about this guy before Gary
Vaynerchuk talks about how it's like
when the Jets do end up winning I don't
know where I'll be and I'd really feel
that way a little bit about I mean I
really love the Patriots continuing to
win the Superbowl but the Sox I mean
with that first series that first time
when we got was a 2004 right I mean that
was just I mean it was elation like I
have never felt for a sports franchise
you know and I understand that winning
and then I was kind of out beating your
rival in that process and destroying
them in leaving them in a heap of ashes
that would add to the excitement and I
understand the concept of spite but when
given the choice can I be elated to the
utmost of elation that my team despite
already having six in the case can win a
seventh that you because Sports is about
greed it is to use the phrase of one
Gordon Gekko good and to use the
phrasing and how many yachts can you
water-ski behind like from Wall Street
the answer is more I get it but for you
to say no no to that ultimate elation I
would rather get
disappointed right at the end of a
journey that I look over the steering
wheel and hope to end with happiness I
would rather be disappointed if it means
my hated team from New York is just as
disappointed and to me that's sad it's
sad Jonathan in every part of my life
rich yeah it's about not looking in the
rearview mirror it's about not
concerning myself with what the
competition is it's about creating my
own happiness and finding a sense of
self satisfaction know whatever I'm
doing okay in the world of Boston sports
mm-hmm that is not the case for me and I
love I will cut my team down as long as
I can in in the process of knowing that
the New York Yankees are being harmed
I'll harm myself where did this come
from where that large oh two one two
nine the People's Republic of
Charlestown nurse cradled and reared in
a city that has 16 public or 62 colleges
and universities that is the beacon of
America the Athens of the world the
cradle of the revolution the reason why
this whole country was founded on the
18th of April in 75 hardly a man is now
alive to remember that famous day in
year the midnight ride of Paul Revere
this is a town that built this country
and this put a light out of democracy to
the rest of the world and as long as the
Yankees lose we're going to be happy
thank you ever heard a better speech you
left out that you left out the duck
boats that's true quack quack they're in
storage right now don't worry they're
gonna be out in February you hope you
ready for Mookie Betts to get traded
though yeah
boy see I've got a bonafide grade-a act
or thespian right here where you cannot
get thrown off your game you just gave
me that stare oh right down the pipe
right there cuz you know Mookie Betts is
going right out the door I got plenty of
tools in our in our tool mugs
there's no flustering this man well I
didn't bang he knew no bounds that's the
the Astro system at Alex Cora was part
of him all right I don't want to keep
throwing you off your game man you are
like I said awesome and everything that
you do I know you're here to promote the
movie Charlie's Angels as well but
sitting on a hill you are incredible in
that illness I appreciate you saying
that you are incredible in that I loved
you and justified as well good it's
really fun to go into different worlds I
mean that's like the most exciting thing
and we and I have talked about you know
how lucky have been to do that it's
incredibly rewarding to go from a place
like Boston set for instance the city on
hill in the 90s to then be and I think
justified was said in not Arkansas know
it was in Kentucky Kentucky that's right
Kentucky in that very contain southern
world West world which is not even of
this word yeah but then that was like a
civil war I got the in my for my
character that was like an old Civil War
right um southern general Major Craddock
or the new Southern Cross right and or
like Kingdom play you know becoming to
like vet the the the world of MMA I mean
getting to just kind of go into these
very authentic worlds and experiences
and then and make an attempt to kind of
reflect some of those people and those
characters it's incredibly rewarding and
it fuels in in some ways very
blue-collar like very it feels like
you're getting to go do a job mmm and
it's really important that you do it
well you know if you if you have a
welder who doesn't do a good job there's
going to be problems course and I feel
that way as an actor when you have the
responsibility of the world
those characters as a part of your your
due diligence and now you again you're
in a reboot of one of the most famous
pop culture I guess titles of our of our
generation in Charlie's Angels with
Elizabeth Banks directing it and she
wrote it too and she's just really
kick-ass really us and so again that's
in theaters near you starting today
before I let you go man you just said
you just got off your fifty first plane
flight right because your American
Airlines we got a good thing okay we got
a real good thing we certainly do and
I'm just hoping for that concierge
achieve that status level that is by
invitation only and if they hear me on
the Rich Eisen show the famous Rich
Eisen show yeah that's right you know
you might get the key to whatever that
ever Kingdom that's we don't know and
you you look well rested and and
terrific certainly for also having a set
of six month-old twins at home right
yeah and my sister is being kind enough
to help feed them as we speak okay yeah
two kids at the same time is not like
two kids it's it should they shouldn't
call it twin people like oh well we have
two kids I'm I guess but not the same
[Laughter]
holding two bottles doing the burp every
two ounces and then once hungry ones not
one sleeping stock yeah it's very
what's amazing is just that and I think
you you were saying this with your
daughters like you can have all this
screaming and yelling and then all of a
sudden they give you one look oh it's oh
my god that's a wrap
he's about to have his first child over
there or actually Sarah's about to have
your last child for the right right
you're together having your your first
child but you're just along for the ride
do you have any parental advice for for
him a fellow Masshole that's sitting
right over there save every dollar it
ain't cheap it's a cat it's a capital
intensive proposition well putz CIP is
why you're all right
it's a YP and a CIP yeah I think it
makes you a better mean you know I've
said a lot of things in my life like the
kind of person that I wanted to be yes
and how I want to experience the world
and then you have these kids and all of
a sudden like you better really live it
and you do end up living it yeah man
cuz they'll smell it out when I mean
your your kids are six months old now
when they get to be six eight eleven as
my kids are right now they sense they
sense everything they pick everything up
they hear everything they sense
everything and you know and I'll say
this because they're in school right now
they ruin everything I mean just
absolutely ruin your sleep your social
life I mean no is this on - that's a the
quiet part out nobody's I cried
commercials now I mean like like you
know you imagine you got to explain to
your kid that you weren't taking a swing
because you knew it was a changeup
because you had a system that was
established did she like what a what a
horrible thing to have to explain to
your kids I can imagine that 2017 you
can't wait to explain that to your kid
well because I mean and I mean I don't
know but you it's like if there's a
little air left out of a ball he could
we can have it now - we've realized now
perfectly they're like essentially every
quarterback has has a little something
and he now has a ball that is up to
every regulation you can imagine and
he's still winning over and over and
over again so he can tell his kid I
never cheated I show it can show you
exactly what I did with the ball that
will check by 50 different people at
every moment of the game that's odd that
you would take a Patriots so-called
scandal and and just sweep it under the
rug with your children it's not sweeping
it under the rug it's explaining - it's
science
[Laughter]
Tom Brady in our household because of my
Susie my wife is from doing the full my
lovely wife yes I mean integrity and
where exactly and and also he's a
Michigan Wolverine it's it's it's a done
deal that Tom Brady has nothing but the
highest of reverence in our household
that said when the Red Sox onesies
started coming to the house from her
side of the family from across the
country or those were that's that's
that's the red line that was not that's
the actually pinstripe line that would
not be crossed in our household that
could not be crossed we got one of each
sent from from a friend of ours so send
up a Yankees home this is a red cell
phone and so what happened to the Yankee
I have never seen that but I did take a
nice photo and send it towards a thank
you just put your child in it no they're
literally never that's I mean I'm not
kidding as literally there's not a
chance did get flushed down the toilet
never happen F&M talker on both Twitter
and Instagram follow this man great to
have you I'm telling you is a fun movie
you'll have a good time a blast
Charlie's Angels in theaters near you
starring Kristen Stewart and Iommi Scott
Allen balance Co olinska is terrific and
Elizabeth Banks as well you Patrick
Stewart and so many more thanks for
coming on the show sir it is thrilled to
be here anytime that's Jonathan Tucker
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app